[Music]
mrs wang are you with us
i am paying attention
now you may only see a pile of receipts
but i see a story
i can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
what's happening
i'm not your husband i'm one of the
fusion if i'm from another universe i'm
here because we need your help
[Music]
very busy today so time to help you
across the multiverse
i've seen thousands of evolutions
you can access all the memories their
emotions
even the skills
there's a great evil spreading the many
verses and you
may be your only chance of stopping it
don't make me [ __ ] you i am really good
i don't believe you
he's waiting in the wings the universe
he speaks of senseless things is so much
bigger
than you realized
[Music]
remember our mission concerning the fate
of every single world of our infinite
multiverse
there is no way i am the everland you
are looking for
every rejection
every disappointment
has led you here
to this
moment
don't let anything distract you from
[Music]
it
my life
[Music]
[Music]
you